so i've spent a couple videos laying
down the foundation for what
three-dimensional curl is trying to
represent and here i'm going to go ahead
and talk about how you actually compute
it
so 3d curl is the kind of thing that you
take with regards to a three-dimensional
vector field so something that takes in
a three-dimensional point as its input
and then it's gonna output a
three-dimensional vector and it's common
to write the component functions as um p
q and r so each one of these is a scalar
valued function that takes in a
three-dimensional point and just outputs
a number so it'll be that same 3d point
with the coordinates x y and z
x y
and z
so when you have a three dimensional
vector field like this the image you
might have in mind would be something
like this
where
every point in three-dimensional space
has a vector attached to it and you know
when you actually look at it it's
there's quite a lot going on but in
principle all that's really happening is
that each point in space is associated
with a vector and the point in space is
the input and the vector is the output
and you're just kind of gluing them
together and naturally because between
the three dimensions of the input and
the three dimensions of the output we
have six dimensions going on the picture
that you're looking at becomes quite
messy
so the question is
how do you how do you compute this curl
value that i've been talking about
curl
of your vector valued function
and just as a as a quick reminder what
this is supposed to be is you're going
to have some kind of fluid flow induced
by this vector field where you're
imagining like air flowing along each
vector and what you want is a function
that tells you at any given point what
is the rotation induced by that fluid
flow around that point and because
rotation is described with a
three-dimensional vector you're
expecting this to be vector valued it'll
be something that equals a vector output
and if that if that doesn't make sense
if that doesn't quite jive
maybe go check out the video on how to
represent three-dimensional rotation
with a vector so what you have here it's
going to be something that takes as its
input x y and z it takes a three
dimensional point and what it outputs is
a vector describing rotation and there's
actually another notation that's quite
quite helpful when it comes to computing
this where you take nabla that upside
down triangle we used in divergence and
gradient and you imagine taking the
cross product between that and your
vector v
and as a reminder this nabla you imagine
it as if it's a vector containing
partial differential operators and
that's the kind of thing where when you
say it out loud it sounds kind of fancy
a vector full of partial differential
operators but all it really means is i'm
just going to write a bunch of symbols
and this like partial partial x is
something that wants to take in a
function a multivariable function and
tell you its partial derivative
and you know strictly speaking this
doesn't really make sense like hey how
can a vector contain these partial
differential operators but as a series
of symbolic movements it's actually
quite helpful because when you're
multiplying these guys by a thing
it's not really multiplication you're
really going to be giving it some kind
of multivariable function like p q or r
the component functions of our vector
field and evaluating it
so just as a warm up for how to do this
let's see what this looks like in the
case of two dimensions where we already
kind of know the formula for
two-dimensional curl
so what that would look like is you have
a a smaller more two-dimensional just
partial partial x partial partial y
you know
del operator
and you're going to take the cross
product between that and a two
dimensional vector that's just the
component functions p
and q and in this case p and q would be
uh just functions of x and y so i'm kind
of overloading notation right over here
i have a a two dimensional vector field
that i'm saying p and y are scalar
valued functions with a two dimensional
input but over here i'm also using p and
q to represent ones with a
three-dimensional input um so you should
think of these as separate but it's
common to use the same names and this is
just kind of going to illustrate the
broader kind of more complicated point
so when you compute something like this
the cross product you typically think of
it as taking these diagonal components
and multiplying them so that would be
your partial partial x quote unquote
multiplied with q which really means
you're taking the partial derivative of
q with respect to x and then you
subtract off this diagonal component
here which is um let's see so partial
partial oh sorry this should be a y this
should be partial partial y so okay
sorry about that eating partial partial
y of p and that's what you're
subtracting off so partial partial y
of p so just the partial derivative of
that p function with respect to y and
hopefully this is something you
recognize this is the two-dimensional
curl and it's something we got an
intuition for i want it to be more than
just a formula
but hopefully this is kind of reassuring
that when you take that del operator
that nabla symbol and cross product with
the vector-valued function itself it
gives you a sense of curl now when we do
this in the three-dimensional case we're
going to take a three-dimensional cross
product between this three-dimensional
vector-ish thing and this
three-dimensional function and that
would be a good time by the way if
you're not terribly comfortable with the
cross product of how to compute it or
how to interpret it and things like that
that would probably be a good time to go
find the videos that sal does on this
and
build up that intuition for what a cross
product actually is and how to compute
it
because at this point i'm going to
assume that you know how to compute it
because because we're doing it in kind
of an absurd context of partial
differential operators and functions so
it's important to have that that
foundation so the way you compute a
thing like this is you construct a
determinant so i'm going to go down here
determinant
of a certain three by three matrix
and the top row of that is all of the
unit vectors in various directions of
three-dimensional space so these i j and
k guys i represents the unit vector in
the x direction so that would be i is
equal to
you know x component is one but then the
other components are zero
and then similarly j and k represent the
unit vectors in the
y and z direction and again if that
doesn't quite make sense uh why i'm
putting them up there or what we're
about to do maybe check out that cross
product video
so we put those in the top rows as
vectors and this is kind of the trick to
computing the cross product because
again it's like what does it mean to put
a vector inside a matrix but it's it's a
notational trick
and then we're going to take the first
vector that we're doing the cross
product with and put its components in
the next row
so what that would look like is the next
row has a
partial y
and a partial
oh sorry again i keep keep messing up
here that's an x
you do whatever the first component is
first and then the second component
second and the third component the z
partial partial z
i don't know why i'm making that little
mistake
and then for the last row you put in the
second vector which in this case is
vector valued function p q and r
p which is a multivariable function q
and r
and uh first is worth stepping back and
looking at this
this is kind of an absurd thing that
usually when we talk about matrices and
taking the determinant all of the
components are numbers because you're
multiplying numbers together but here
we've got like a notational trick
layered on top of a notational trick so
that one of the rows is vectors one of
the rows is like partial differential
operators and then the last one each one
of these is a multi-variable function so
it seems like this absurd convoluted as
far away from a matrix full of numbers
thing as you can get but it's actually
very helpful for computation because if
you go through the process of computing
this determinant and saying what could
that mean the thing that pops out is
going to be the formula for
three-dimensional curl and at the risk
of having a video that runs too long
i'll call things in in here but continue
going through that operation in the next
video see you then